He was an economically rational person.
He said to his sweetie, "Let us marry.
Let us merge our interests."
(Laughter)
Yes, he did.
"I love you truly," he said. "I love you deeply.
I love you more than any other woman I've ever encountered.
I love you more than Mary, Jane, Susie, Penelope,
Ingrid, Gertrude, Gretel --
I was on a German exchange program then.
I love you more than --"
All right.
She left the room
halfway through his enumeration of his love for her.
After he got over his surprise at being, you know, turned down,
he concluded he'd had a narrow escape
from marrying an irrational person.
Although, he did make a note to himself that the next time he proposed,
it was perhaps not necessary
to enumerate all of the women he had auditioned for the part.
(Laughter)
But the point stands.
You must look for alternatives so that you find your destiny,
or are you afraid of the word "destiny"?
Does the word "destiny" scare you?
That's what we're talking about.
And if you don't find the highest expression of your talent,
if you settle for "interesting," what the hell ever that means,
do you know what will happen at the end of your long life?
Your friends and family will be gathered in the cemetery,
and there beside your gravesite will be a tombstone,
and inscribed on that tombstone
it will say, "Here lies a distinguished engineer,
who invented Velcro."
But what that tombstone should have said,
in an alternative lifetime,
what it should have said if it was your highest expression of talent,
was, "Here lies the last Nobel Laureate in Physics,
who formulated the Grand Unified Field Theory
and demonstrated the practicality of warp drive."
(Laughter)
Velcro, indeed!
One was a great career.
One was a missed opportunity.
But then, there are some of you who,
in spite of all these excuses, you will find,
you will find your passion.
And you'll still fail.
You're going to fail, because --
because you're not going to do it,
because you will have invented a new excuse,
any excuse to fail to take action,
and this excuse, I've heard so many times:
"Yes, I would pursue a great career,
but, I value human relationships --
(Laughter)
more than accomplishment.
I want to be a great friend.
I want to be a great spouse.
I want to be a great parent,
and I will not sacrifice them
on the altar of great accomplishment."
(Laughter)
What do you want me to say?
Now, do you really want me to say now, tell you,
"Really, I swear I don't kick children."
(Laughter)
Look at the worldview you've given yourself.
You're a hero no matter what.
And I, by suggesting ever so delicately
that you might want a great career, must hate children.
I don't hate children. I don't kick them.
Yes, there was a little kid wandering through this building
when I came here, and no, I didn't kick him.
(Laughter)
Course, I had to tell him the building was for adults only,
and to get out.
He mumbled something about his mother,
and I told him she'd probably find him outside anyway.
Last time I saw him, he was on the stairs crying.
(Laughter)
What a wimp.
But what do you mean? That's what you expect me to say.
Do you really think it's appropriate
that you should actually take children and use them as a shield?
You know what will happen someday,
you ideal parent, you?
The kid will come to you someday and say,
"I know what I want to be.
I know what I'm going to do with my life."
You are so happy.
It's the conversation a parent wants to hear,
because your kid's good in math,
and you know you're going to like what comes next.
Says your kid,
"I have decided I want to be a magician.
I want to perform magic tricks on the stage."
(Laughter)
And what do you say?
You say, you say,
"That's risky, kid.
Might fail, kid. Don't make a lot of money at that, kid.
I don't know, kid, you should think about that again, kid.
You're so good at math, why don't you --"
The kid interrupts you and says,
"But it is my dream. It is my dream to do this."
And what are you going to say?
You know what you're going to say?
"Look kid. I had a dream once, too, but --
But --"
So how are you going to finish the sentence with your "but"?
"But. I had a dream too, once, kid, but I was afraid to pursue it."
Or are you going to tell him this:
"I had a dream once, kid.
But then, you were born."
(Laughter)
(Applause)
Do you really want to use your family,
do you really ever want to look at your spouse and your kid,
and see your jailers?
There was something you could have said to your kid,
when he or she said, "I have a dream."
You could have said --
looked the kid in the face and said,
"Go for it, kid!
Just like I did."
But you won't be able to say that,
because you didn't.
So you can't.
(Laughter)
And so the sins of the parents
are visited on the poor children.
Why will you seek refuge in human relationships
as your excuse not to find and pursue your passion?
You know why.
In your heart of hearts, you know why,
and I'm being deadly serious.
You know why you would get all warm and fuzzy
and wrap yourself up in human relationships.
It is because you are --
you know what you are.
You're afraid to pursue your passion.
You're afraid to look ridiculous.
You're afraid to try.
You're afraid you may fail.
Great friend, great spouse, great parent, great career.
Is that not a package? Is that not who you are?
How can you be one without the other?
But you're afraid.
And that's why you're not going to have a great career.
Unless --
"unless," that most evocative of all English words --
"unless."
But the "unless" word is also attached
to that other, most terrifying phrase,
"If only I had ..."
If you ever have that thought ricocheting in your brain,
it will hurt a lot.
So, those are the many reasons
why you are going to fail
to have a great career.
Unless --
Unless.
Thank you.
(Applause)